how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
today we have some
exciting news about spider-man 3. now as
i mentioned in a recent
video marvel studios is basically opened
back up
the crew for the falcon and the winter
soldier the loki
series and the hawkeye series has
already moved back into atlanta to begin
preparation for filming of these shows
so marvel production is back and at it
which means we're going
to start to get a lot more news a lot
more leaks photos and
videos and if you cut one of my update
videos on spider-man 3
you know that production for spider-man
3 is going to happen sometime this fall
and this has been confirmed by tom
holland
himself he confirmed that once he's done
filming uncharted he will begin
in the fall filming spider-man 3. and
fall is only about
one month away which means marvel
studios right now is getting ready
to film spider-man 3 which means they're
getting a lot of things in order and one
of those things that they are getting in
order right now is the villain
for spider-man 3 and it seems like today
we might have found out
who that villain is and we also may have
found out the actor that marvel studios
is eyeing
for that role so i'll break down
everything that you need to know about
this report
in this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest
mcu news and a big congratulations to
youtube
user 2 three you're the winner of the
gambit funko pop just email me in the
email in my about me section and we'll
get you your funko pop and this week
we're giving away a
mysterio funko pop so all you have to do
to enter subscribe
like this video and leave a comment down
below so today's report about
spider-man 3 and our possible discovery
of who the villain is is coming from
charles murphy charles has a pretty
great track record when it comes to his
reports
and in this report it seems like
spider-man 3 may have found its villain
and
the actor that it wants to play the
villain now this is pretty big news
because we actually don't know that much
about spider-man 3. marvel and sony have
kept a pretty tight lid
on what the plot for it actually is we
have somewhat of an idea of what the
plot for it could
be since the last time we saw spider-man
he was being framed for murder
we also know that flash thompson one of
peter's classmates is going to be
returning
jk simmons is going to be returning and
reprising his role as
j jonah jameson and of course zendaya is
returning as well
and now based off of this recent report
from charles murphy it seems like
craven the hunter could be the villain
for spider-man 3.
now this has been something that has
been speculated a lot in the past as
well
but there's a difference in our
speculation today as there is a little
bit more proof to back this up
according to charles murphy's report
today on his website
murphy's multiverse.com he says it
appears that marvel studios is looking
for a
joel kinnaman type for an unspecified
role in the upcoming
untitled spider-man sequel so a joel
kinnaman type for an unspecified role in
spider-man 3.
now charles murphy specifically states
that it only says they're looking for
a kinnaman type for an unspecified role
however if we think about who he could
be playing
everything points towards him playing
craven the hunter and even charles
murphy says that he would be perfect for
it as well
also keep in mind that marvel studios
says joel kinnaman type
just like they said in the past about
she-hulk allison brie
type they say that just in case they
can't get the actor that they want so
right now they're eyeing joel kinnaman
for craven the hunter but if they can't
get him they'll get somebody close to
him and that actually says
a lot about the character that means
they're looking for a white male
between 30 to 45 someone who is
physically big or at least can pack on
the pounds to get physically big
which we know joel kinnaman can because
he has done it in the past for roles and
somebody who is also a pretty big
actor someone who's had experience doing
big movies and
comic book movies which joel kinneman
has because he was in the suicide squad
but those details a white caucasian who
is big
in size and between 30 to 45 years old
fits the bill for craven the hunter if
we're talking about any of the other
spider-man characters
like doctor octopus or norman osborn he
doesn't really fit the bill it's much
too young of a character to be osborne
and it's much too of a physically big
character to be doc
and it doesn't really match anyone in
the sinister six as well so
it looks like marvel's casting him or
trying to cast somebody like him
for craven the hunter making craven the
hunter the villain
for spider-man 3. now if this does in
fact end up being true
it makes a lot of sense spider-man is on
the run
craven is a hunter a bounty hunter
someone could possibly hire craven to
track down spider-man it could even be
norman osborne heck it could even be j
jonah jameson we don't really know much
about the plot right now
however there have been two rumors that
have gone around that are pretty
interesting now keep in mind they're
just rumors and not confirmed in any way
but they are interesting nonetheless and
one
is that craven the hunter will have some
kind of connection
to wakanda perhaps he's hunted there
before now this is very interesting but
it also goes with the
other rumor that black panther could end
up being in spider-man 3 as well
now we pretty much know that from here
on out each marvel movie
is going to have a lot of characters in
it after all the superhero world is
pretty big now and a lot of the heroes
know each other so it would make sense
that in their films they would ask for
help and in this case if peter has a
bounty hunter tracking him down who was
tracked before
in wakanda it would make sense that he
would go to t'challa he would try and
get some information from t'challa he
would try
and figure out a way to stop this guy
because we have to remember that peter
is still just a teenager he's still kind
of just a kid
he's going to need some help in each
spider-man film he had help and the
first one he had tony
and the second one he had happy and kind
of nick fury and maria hill who was
secretly talos and his wife
but another thing about this villain
would be that he would actually kind of
be
sort of a co-lead if we look back to
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home
both actors that played the villains
were huge actors
michael keaton and jake gyllenhaal but
they were also huge as far as their
presence was concerned they were
basically co-leads to the movie
especially mysterio
so it seems like spider-man 3 may follow
that as well which is why they would
need a pretty big actor that has some
really good experience
in comic book movies such as joel
kinnaman and if we think about it he
really is the perfect fit to play
craven the hunter he's 6-2 he can be
really muscular to play the role and if
you look at his face it actually really
works for craven the hunter and he has
experience doing comic book movies
because of the suicide squad so marvel
really does
know how to cast now one thing that is
very interesting
is that if this truly is the villain of
spider-man 3 that actually means that
there's probably somebody behind
craven now craven is one of spider-man's
most notable enemies
he's a huge spider-man enemy but he's
also a bounty hunter so the question
is if craven the hunter is the villain
of spider-man 3 which seems very very
likely now due to this casting call
the question is who hired him who put
the bounty
on spider-man's head and does he want
him dead or alive
we know that marvel and sony are now
playing very nicely with each other
in fact we know that spider-man is
supposed to go on and lead the new
avengers along with captain marvel so
spider-man should be in the mcu for a
pretty long time now
this means that it is very possible that
whoever
hired craven the hunter to take down
spider-man could be the next
spider-man villain in the next film we
get and this could be
norman osborne this could be doctor doom
this could be somebody truly
big and perhaps we could be getting the
introduction of the next
major villain not to just spider-man but
to the mcu in its entirety
in spider-man 3. now again keep in mind
that charles murphy says that the cast
and call did not mention craven it just
mentioned
an untitled role for spider-man 3 but
everything about the description seems
to fit the bill of craven the hunter so
it seems like
that's going to be the villain of
spider-man 3. so let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below would you be happy
with carving the hunter being the main
villain of spider-man 3
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always
thank you all so much for watching woof